Russian Diplomat turned squatter
he's the latest challenge for Australian
officials trying to block Russia from
building a new Embassy in Canberra but
prime minister Anthony Albanese says the
Russian man isn't a threat to National
Security the national security threat
that was represented by a Russian
Embassy on site are not the same as some
black standing on a blade of grass on
the site that we don't see really as a
threat to our national security
unable to arrest the man because he has
diplomatic immunity the Russian Embassy
says he's there to quote ensure the
safety of the site the location is close
to Parliament House intelligence
agencies say the embassy could be used
to spy on Australian politicians it's
very close to Parliament House it's an
align of sight between the major
telecommunications Tower and Parliament
House it gives them an enormous
Advantage for eavesdropping for
intelligence gathering and given what
we've seen in Ukraine and the approach
that Russia has taken to relations
globally that's just not acceptable in
Australia any longer
Russia bought the lease to the land from
the Australian government in 2008 and
was granted approval to build a new
Embassy in 2011 but last week
Australia's parliament passed
legislation to terminate Russia's
tenancy Australia
unfortunately for us Australia continues
to move zealously in the wake of the
authors of the russophobic hysteria that
is now going on in the countries of the
collective West Australia is trying to
be a standout amongst these countries
Russia's launched a high court challenge
to canberra's decision on the grounds
that it's against Australia's
Constitution and until vets decided this
Diplomat seems likely to stand his
ground Alex beard Al Jazeera